it's like this i'm gonna try to power
through this in record time because
quite frankly i didn't have fun with
this movie i don't care to talk about it
you don't care to hear about it i know
this because when i went to the
auditorium to watch this movie i was
like whoa pickens are slim on seats but
i was the only one in the auditorium so
let's get you all the information and as
little time as possible
[Music]
so firestarter is a new firestarter
adaptation see it as a remake of the old
movie see it as a new adaptation of the
stephen king book the universe does not
care how you view it because the
universe does not care about this movie
basically the story is the super cd
government-ish organization did some
experiments on people back in the day
which this takes place in modern day it
makes more sense when the stephen king
novel came out like oh the parents were
experimented on with lsd and other drugs
you know government style mid-century
[ __ ] but i guess in 2010 that was
happening too so basically this little
girl who can start fighting with her
mind and her dad played by zac efron who
are on the run
there's nothing else i could say it
sounds more interesting like a
father-daughter pair on the run when the
daughter is trying to learn her powers
that actually sounds like it could be
interesting an interesting series i'm
telling you if the adaptation was a
netflix series or something and you had
all those episodes to really flesh it
out and have her learning her powers and
bonding with her dad so you actually you
know care this should be one of those
series that would be like the thing to
talk about i get all these i'd be
inundated with comments like dude why
aren't you talking about fire starter
you'd be trending you'd be crazy well i
mean you have to have good writers and
directors on board too that's important
as it stands it's just this really
forgettable slog boar fest of a mess and
that's this movie and no one's talking
about it no one's even seeing it but i
actually i saw the trailer for this i
was like this might be good well [ __ ] me
for hoping the movie's about 90 minutes
long it's just not long enough for me to
care about the parents to care about
this girl and her dad and their dynamic
to care about this hitman out there
who's coming after them who also has
powers of his own but the head agent in
here i'm not talking about the hitman
but i'm talking about the one who runs
the
the dude wasn't buying it this was not
matthew modine i'm not talking dark
knight rises matthew modine you know i'm
talking matthew modine stranger things
matthew modine they needed someone like
that to head up this organization as it
stands just this lady that i was like
all right i guess you're the boss i
don't care i don't okay now that's over
the movie's also filmed to have a muddy
boring ass color palette a lot of movies
these days are because they're filmed in
digital and digital is just
naturally less colorful than 35
millimeter but you know some people put
in some effort for color correction in
post this movie was like not screw that
in fact i wouldn't be surprised if they
were like let's dull the colors let's
dull the already dull colors a huge
tragedy in this movie is kurtwood smith
is in one scene he's like this old
doctor who headed up this experiment
back in the day and head director of cd
organization lady's like we want you to
come back to the organization and you're
like oh yeah all right he's gonna bring
something to this movie i'm ready babe
you never see him again
in the entire film he's in a scene that
looks like was a called in favor like
someone was like hey man it's me what's
up
you know me
the
you know from easter
you
right i was the one juggling the deviled
eggs i can't believe you remember that
anyhow i'm a huge fan and i love robocop
and we just did this movie and he needs
something you mind if you come in and
we'll just film scenes and put you in
there
yeah
scenes isn't plural
can't talk you anymore
all right one scene we'll make it work
how much
we're gonna have to cut the move
okay deal
he's coming and he was in the movie and
it didn't help because the whole time
i'm like where is he in the movie
because in the end fire starter it lit
no fire for me the only fire in this
movie is the bus fire that is the film
itself i was just it was 90 minutes of
me being bored to death and there is no
reality where i remember this movie in t
minus one day yep already you're being
too nice am i being too nice
[ __ ] it it's a flaming bag of dog [ __ ]
all right now video's done it's over
hopefully it didn't drag on too much in
the words of the great shredder from
teenage mutant ninja turtles 2 secret of
the use go play have fun but what's a
stephen king book that you would like to
see adapted to a movie or a series what
i'm looking forward to coming out
salem's lot for me whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you